hmm
[Laughter]
um
[Laughter]
i have with me david pakman he is a
progressive host
an executive producer of the
nationally syndicated radio and tv
program the david pacman show
and i wanted to talk to david pacman
he is a baby
[Music]
david patman
he is
[Music]
can you remind the audience when you
talk about being a beta male and being
an alpha male what are we talking about
here
there are males most men today yeah male
1 they think and act like a woman they
are emotional
they are mentally off they have no logic
and that's a beta male they go along
with homosexuality hold on but holy whoa
whoa jesse well we gotta that's a lot
that's a lot hang on agree with
everything that's raw abortion they
think and act just like a woman a beta
male died but another baby
doesn't because he's a logical thinking
and they're controlled by the darkness
of david pacman
he is a baby
[Music]
david patman
he is
[Music]
[Applause]
david
he is a beta male 1
[Music]
david pacman
he is a baby
david you're not here to communicate i
really appreciate you coming out i'm
going gonna let you go it's a waste of
time to talk to you we're not
communicating you're actually like
because you're asking bizarre questions
you're actually like
and you're wasting my time i appreciate
that
all right thank you for coming by
goodbye
[Applause]
that's a progressive vote
all men who are progressive or
[Music]
[Music]
now that we are up under our bodies
regime
my bag of mangoes now cost 11.99
that seems like a pretty good deal a bag
of mangoes mango aren't measures like
three boxes
that's it
eight or eleven bucks
[Music]
bring my mangoes back down
[Music]
[Music]
the wisconsin crowd identifying with the
mangoes
[Applause]
the american people
don't want me to be healthy
healthy
to be
healthy if highway robbery is
[Music]
wow what an incredible sweet serenade of
fruits and vegetables
uh to get us started today
the fourth day the fourth day now of
deliberation in the kyle rittenhouse
trial the deliberation has been going on
so long
that
the
trial over the killing of ahmad arbory
has now seen the defense rest and is now
um we there is a charge conference going
on related to the charges
and even that case now
is moving forward so what a day now i
have again spoken to some defense
attorneys and prosecutor one prosecutor
even this morning
and there is something sort of special
about friday deliberations
when you've been deliberating quite
frankly most of the week which is there
are jurors it's a known thing
that jurors are thinking about their
weekends
and if possible
if possible
many jurors would prefer not to have the
continuing duty that they have to
discharge of
finding a verdict
hanging over their head the entire
weekend now of course there's examples
of everything in some courts they're
allowed to deliberate on the weekends if
they say we want to deliberate on the
weekend the judge would would set it up
for them etc etc so anything can can be
the case but
uh it is often the case that as you get
closer to the weekend particularly with
a short holiday week next week
um jurors are saying we want to be done
we want to be done with this and uh that
is going to be something we're going to
be looking at very strongly today
as the jury is about to complete 24
hours of deliberation if you can imagine
24 hours of deliberation
um we are just
32 and a half 32 minutes and 15 seconds
from the start of our 25
of deliberations
let's briefly listen to what's happening
here in this other trial because this
one is basically just as interesting if
you're not familiar with the process the
word charge doesn't mean a criminal
charge it literally means an instruction
to
jurors and they're hashing it out there
in brunswick georgia here in kenosha
wisconsin the clock continues to tick
the jury deliberating the fate of kyle
rittenhouse our team is inside the
courtroom
and outside the courthouse if anything
happens of course any question any
development we'll get you live into the
courtroom here in kenosha we'll also dip
in throughout the morning during this
charge conference in brunswick georgia
we'll step aside take a break right now
you're watching for tv your front row
seat to justice
all right so that's what's going on we
are watching all of it very closely if
anybody has a feed from outside the
courthouse i would love it i wasn't able
to find one
this morning but things are happening i
do want to say thank you to christy lamb
who is today's first new member at
joinpakman.com with the coupon code
uncharged pickles uncharged piccolos we
may be down to the last few hours of
that coupon code i do want to make sure
everybody understands when we have a
verdict the code uncharged pickles is
done maybe at that point i don't know we
switched to millibytes
megabyte it was a four millibate video
millibyte exactly um okay let's see
what's on people's minds and see what
people are thinking here as we go into
day four of deliberations
um let's see
will you drop the link to mangoes in the
chat i don't have a link it's like a
file i have on my computer
um pac daddy i'm more invested in this
stream series than i should be i am i
mean listen at this point i want to see
what is happening what is go what i want
to see this through to the end
um horgus blourgis says as a concerned
friend i thought your point about
destiny being very mad at trivial things
was fair and the way he got defensive
was alarming yeah i the reaction to
yesterday's conversation with destiny
was totally off the charts and and all
over the place whoa very shaky camera we
may be having something happening here
there were people who thought i came off
as winning and people who thought i came
off as losing and people who thought i
was kidding when i asked destiny about
the autism i wouldn't ever joke about
something like that ever ever ever i was
just asking
i i know plenty of people who are just
mildly autistic and sometimes they don't
you know they they get very mad at
something that's minor or whatever it
was totally genuine there's nothing
funny about autism period i mean that
that's it
um but yeah people saying that just you
know i completely collapsed or destiny
collapsed or would i have to tell you
i'm bored with it i didn't even know it
was gonna explode the way it did
um
oh hold on
we've got some let's go brandon and some
free kyle stuff to ban here
oh man it's it is sad when we have to
ban so many people
okay there it is maybe it's your destiny
to not be friends with him anymore
you remind me of david spade it's a
compliment david where did the sir your
wife is up in the air clip come from sir
your wife is up in the air trump was at
a rally or something and he was saying
that his wife was in a helicopter is
what he meant
i don't know it's kind of a funny clip
um so there there we have that as far as
that goes i want to say thank you to
henry engeval who just signed up on my
website joinpakman.com coupon code was
uncharged uncharged piccolos pickles you
are new member number two today
very much appreciate you henry and yes
patreon continues to count double okay
do we know of any live streams right now
outside the courthouse i would love to
see what's happening there
let me see
if i look at
kenosha courthouse
and then we look at
live elements
ruptly does not have anything live
outside the courthouse they have this
very same shot
pbs and law and crime we know about
um
let's see what's up with snack squad
no snack squad has got the same thing as
us
i'm not seeing anybody who's live
outside the courthouse right now
if anybody has one you can let me know
yeah we don't need a kenosha police
scanner that doesn't seem necessary
okay
yeah so i'm not seeing that
um david how about you give everyone
during the verdict free pickles i'll
take valsik dill oh give me a break pac
daddy why does patreon count double when
website subs are more valuable to you
we've made the calculation that there's
more people in the audience who are not
yet pledged on patreon so we believe
it's potentially a larger pool of people
but
none of the there's no big you know
this is just a live stream on the
internet guys it's not nothing nothing
is so you know
serious
internets are not as serious business as
some people think i want to say thank
you to scott stahl and simi saran
new members three and four today on my
website
david do you think the unban button is
due to you having to ban so many people
lately no i don't think so i don't think
so as funny as that idea is i don't
think that that is the case all right
let me jump because we have such a
hectic day i want to jump right into a
few voicemails here that have been
received related to the trial i do have
to ban let's go brandon all caps is an
insta-ban
it's just we there's just no tolerance
for it it's insta-ban you're gone and
there's a glitch right now on youtube
with unbanning so it's sort of like
every ban is default a perma-ban sadly
or
gleefully right now
um
i think we got everybody there
good okay let's get to a few um
a few voicemails here
hey david this is b-dog uh
i was sitting here having my morning
mountain dew gingerbread snapped and
i was thinking to myself
hypothetically if kyle written dog goes
to prison
do you think it would be good for
good for tile dog or do you think he
would be further radicalized in prison
dog i'll take my answer off the air pack
dog i think that uh written house in
prison
is a real question mark he doesn't
strike me necessarily as the guy to get
even more radicalized that's one way it
can go in prison the other one is you're
sort of like scared straight to some
degree
i mean he's barely an adult
so um
yeah david what are your favorite spots
to eat in la yes i'm gonna be very
powerfully in los angeles soon for a
period of time that we're looking at
very strongly
um i i mean l.a there's so many great
spots there's a lot of great spots
actually in north hollywood a less
touristy neighborhood which i like
um i'm a fan of sugarfish it's it's sort
of like a mini chain there's one in new
york i think miami and a couple in la
great sushi
what else do i like in la
there's a place i went to with hassan
[ __ ] and stephen kenneth destiny
bonnell the second
and uh molina destiny bonnell the second
and my manager
uh an indian place
hold on let's see
indian food west
hollywood let me see if i can find the
name of the place
10 best indian restaurant i hope it was
one of the best ten jeez
none of these
it's kind of like a fusion indian place
i don't even know how to describe it
oh what was the name of this place
hassan got some great uh great
chickens thighs there it was interesting
yeah i can't find the name of it
god what was the name of this place
yeah it's not a chain and it's not it's
not chipotle guys
um
you know it's like three locations
all right well anyway
david sir thank you for your outstanding
trial coverage appreciate elements you
powerfully blink to it bring to it will
you play the obama song when you have
time it's my favorite yeah i don't even
know where it is
oh wait jethro
bradley obama oh here it is yeah i
haven't played this in a while we can
listen to it real quick it looks like
something may be happening so we're
gonna keep an eye out here
oh it's muted for some reason
[Music]
god bless
[Music]
i think you mean osama when i smoke a
blunt it's always marijuana the dude
from tibet the dalai lama le mans
[Music]
all right so there it is that's a
special request it looks like something
is happening here i also was sent a feed
i guess from the courthouse this is nbc
oh okay
wow so there's already a crowd it's only
9 23 in the morning and there's already
a crowd
uh at the courthouse so a potential for
a dicey day
for sure
so we're gonna be monitoring that very
closely as well
um
okay
pac daddy why not shout out youtube
memberships like you do web and patreon
p and l i l y oh my god
put i'm not autistic i'm hispanic on the
sound board
i emailed you a live okay yep we got it
favorite spots in l.a did the defense
initially try to dismiss with prejudice
on friday and shift without on wednesday
um i did not see that on friday myself
reconciliation bill passed david what do
you think haven't looked at it yet so i
wouldn't be able to say pretty pretty
busy with this right now
um
if this kid does not walk free wisconsin
will have deserved the damages of last
year and dare i say they will deserve
another burning with double damage
that's very aggressive that's extremely
extremely aggressive
um i do want to say thank you to tony
blackman who just made a pledge via
patreon those count double folks puts us
at six also thanks to martin segura and
jake manderfield who just signed up on
my website joinedpakman.com
numbers seven and eight let's get back
to a few voicemails
about the trial
let's see what we've got here
david i cannot totally agree with you
and your reddit poster
about the messaging with regards to the
rittenhouse trial
and how uh the left is at a great
disadvantage to the right
especially the part where you say
uh
that on the left
we what was like force i'm thinking now
okay i'm going to move on here let's
listen to a few others
the patriotic loving people of america
and
australia will join forces
they will protest and rise up against
their man it's just he's barely audible
barely barely audible
hey david peckman
uh this is woody underwood
calling from racine wisconsin
uh
i'm calling because you did a video
on the q anon shannon
the shaman yeah got it i mean come on
guys come on
hey david if you're from mass i just uh
you know i don't know where you're gonna
go from here you've made a complete and
utter fool out of yourselves
you've got the wrong horse i begged you
i called you to try to tell you i always
thought you were a nice guy i always
thought you were working for the best
interest of people
but i mean this guy's been calling me
for a year saying i'm completely bad
faith dishonest liar when did he think i
was doing all these great things
i don't know this is
i don't know what you're gonna do now i
mean
what are you gonna do
you [ __ ] up the biggest story in the
history of the world
i don't even know what he's talking
about
all right let's see if we have anything
else on the trial here
hey david
dave in california
it looks like ben shapiro put something
out
on youtube
that says
there's going to be civil unrest in
kenosha
and all the comments
are referring to all these black people
that are going to write it now
and burn down all these places and
and all this and
and it's just making it sound like black
people are gonna go crazy
but i don't think any black people are
gonna riot why would they
it was a very young white guy with an
ar-15
who shot
three other white guys killing two
right
okay very good uh let's see what else
we've got on youtube people
in the comments sections
of
videos about the kyle rittenhouse case
in wisconsin
they keep on talking about one of the
victims and they keep on basically
dragging that victim through the mud
and they keep on saying well there were
cases against this person you know
they're you know they're a pedophile
they're registered sex offender or
something or other uh some type of um
sexual assault
type of uh cases against this individual
yeah they've been talking about that
with rosenbaum for a while
um
let's see
cawthorne was dipping during mccarthy's
speech oh is that right
let's see if we can find that that's
bizarre
can i find that
cothorn tobacco
oh yeah look at this man look at this
this i just can't stand this guy
every great society has collapsed
unfortunately
[Music]
this guy
man i just dislike everything about that
guy
that's really something
um when i hear the right complaint about
the jury being pressured by blm are we
to believe it doesn't go both ways blm
isn't outside with assault rifles true
thank you david for reading my super
chats i work at a grocery store i try to
super chat i also have autism so
sometimes it's hard to type well we
welcome your super chats thank you
did you hear bill back better pass the
house i i just did pappy told me i don't
i don't know anything about it yet
calling him pillow made me laugh like a
lunatic can we get a stir your calzones
up in the air i don't have that right
now hoping for an h3 podcast appearance
when in la i like that idea i'm going to
reach out to ethan klein
um and let him know i'm going to be in
la i think that's actually i would love
to appear with him i want to say thanks
to michael hendra who made a pledge via
patreon those count double so that puts
us at 10. today may be the last day for
the uncharged pickles coupon code
uncharged piccolo because we're hoping
for a verdict we're hoping for a verdict
today so we can end this crowd
continuing to gather at the courthouse
at some point maybe we will be able to
get closer to the courthouse so far uh
nothing really big happening we'll go
over to our court tv feed statement
and we're going to keep an eye on it and
see what's going on okay voicemails
continuing to come in about the trial
about yesterday's conversation with
stephen kenneth destiny bonnell ii
hi david
um it's
it's great to listen to your program
it's unique
i'm curious why you are always
following up and
simply
just uh discussing the topics that the
major media is presenting to the u.s
public
there
okay i see that they're asking me why
i'm not talking about what's going on in
africa you know my audience just doesn't
doesn't watch it
so you know to some degree we want to
cover stuff that people
uh that that people are interested in
um
let's see
what else we've got here
david brad from wisconsin first time
caller long time listener great topic
love the show so why isn't anybody
talking about um
my belief and i think it's fact that um
it's not just about self-defense but
it's about
if
he was able to use deadly force in
self-defense if you look up wisconsin
law
you are limited
um
to
using
or not using
deadly force
or causing great bodily harm um unless
it's reasonable okay yeah that's that's
part of what's at issue here
there's another voicemail
david sir jason from hawaii i literally
just got done listening to your
conversation with steven destiny
whatever the long name is anyways dude
every time i listen to him today right
wingers he tears them apart and it's
great but when he was talking to you i
think he did a really good job of
highlighting exactly
where
he was kind of being a little bit overly
hyperbolic and really kind of drilling
him down on points that he was making uh
i thought you did i thought you handled
yourself extremely extremely well uh it
looks like the bridge might still be
intact i love it i think you guys have a
great dynamic uh keep up the
conversations i know that not everyone
in the audience is gonna agree with me
but you guys uh you guys really have
something good going so uh i'd love to
see more of it anyways uh have a good
day bye all right so there's there's one
piece of uh feedback
hey david it's joanne calling from new
york city
i just finished listening to you
uh talking to destiny uh
about the kyle rittenhouse trial and
at the end he destiny said to you twice
i love you how come you didn't say it
back to him
he obviously thinks the world of you
and the other thing i wanted to comment
on was
he
um
i mean
you guys are such good debaters
um anyway very interesting and keep
doing what you're doing oh i know what i
was gonna say um when he asked you about
like
you're giving your opinion on your show
does that sort of
sway people who are listening to you i
mean hopefully people are getting
new information from other news sources
as well right um but i always tend to
agree with you anyway i hope that makes
sense all right so there is another
opinion
hi david shawn from lancaster here
i was just listening to your
conversation with destiny
um i do think there was something to
take away from it insofar as your
audience is probably progressive and his
audience is not
and i think some people can take some
from both sides and maybe meet in the
middle
um i do think it was a little bit
telling
when he said that he just loves to argue
and that he kind of gets off on it and
that when you would agree with him he
was almost like a disarming
like strike that he was kind of
dumbfounded um
uh so i think it was worthwhile uh
thanks for the show keep on keeping on
wow
well there's a there's quite a
perspective
that's quite a perspective more people
would remember that you did this i love
it
i just wanted to make a comment about
destiny
i think you're the most patient person
that i know of because
he was so closed-minded i mean he just
wouldn't even hear you and i think this
is part of the problem with how people
are trying to communicate like he just
had his preconceived notion i don't know
why he's defending the judge who is
obviously wacky and obviously um erring
on the side of helping the defense i
mean it's crazy the judge is just
cr i'm always a gate like so i don't
understand why
kenny is is is defending this judge it's
so bizarre like when he said he was
proficient in technology i mean it's
it's weird like if he has nephew or
something i don't understand it but i
was really struck i
um i listened because i just love your
live streams and i don't want to miss
any of them but at some point i was like
oh david
is
is this guy your friend like i don't
think i'd be patient enough to have a
friend like that i don't mean a friend
who doesn't who has different opinions
than me that's that's fine that's great
but
he's so closed-minded to me he's as
close-minded as anyone on the right who
is insisting that trump has won had won
the election so i just am further struck
by uh your professionalism how fair and
balanced you are oh my god your
knowledge the breadth and depths of your
knowledge and also that the fact that
when you don't know something you'll
tell someone oh i haven't heard that i
have to read on that i i don't know the
answer to that so that's refreshing as
well wow very very nice message i have
to say
um
let's see what else we've got
jimmy from philly has an opinion about
the destiny conversation
david jimmy from philly what
i'm not really liking destiny because
he's
he's killing you david destiny's killing
you
wow what a surprise
jimmy jimmy doesn't like my perspective
david jimmy from philly
what
you do not have an opinion
you're lying david you're [ __ ] lying
do you understand you argue in bad faith
destiny's is been trouncing you he's
kicking smacking you around oh my god i
know nothing about destiny but he's
beating the balls off you i can only
imagine what the heart bastard would do
to you oh my
so there's an opinion from jimmy jimmy
thinks that um
you know okay
so there's that uh there's that and now
we are now everybody knows everybody's
opinion which i think is a great great
thing
curious how things would have turned out
if gross kreutz shot and killed written
house under the believe he was stopping
an active shooter it's a great question
it's actually it's a very good question
i don't have the answer
the q anon shaman is an example of what
happens when the peyote wears off he's
been a meme on the res
uh right
absolutely
absolutely all right welcome everybody
the jury is about to start its 25th hour
of deliberations
um hold on a second we gotta ban a
couple people here
okay
got good we got a couple people banned
we're standing by outside the courthouse
a very small crowd right now okay we're
looking inside the courthouse
and we're also covering other coverage
let's take a look at what's happening
over on the court tv live stream this is
the killing of the trial over the
killing of a mart arbory they are
finalizing charges this case moving very
quickly but i
i would withdraw my objection to it
based on the arguments that i've heard
i do prefer
changing the word difficulties because
i'm not quite sure that matches right in
case
yeah
that word that word is the word and it's
charged so um
and what i mean by that not just that it
sits in the pattern but that is the
defining word in the charge i mean it
really
it either works that way with that idea
my concern is changing the word changes
really the nature of the charge too much
that's why i'm going to think it through
i'll come back to that
all right
um
so with regard to our next section which
is identification we have two sections
we have 1.35.10
identification reliability and then we
have 1.35.11
identification burden of proof the court
obviously noted that i did not put in
the reliability one and the reason for
that is this is not a case of
mistaken identity it's not a some other
dude did it case it is not a case where
we have anything in dispute officer
minchi showed up on the scene and
there's photographs of all three
defendants standing there it has not
been any sort of identification issue
they were all identified by law
enforcement officers who took the stand
and travis mcmichael took the stand and
said yes you know that was me that's
what i did
so
this charge in the state's mind is not
really appropriate because it really
talks about the opportunity of the
witness to view the alleged perpetrator
at the time of the alleged incident we
don't really have any of that
possibility of mistaken identity don't
have that
was the witness's identification
influenced by factors well this isn't an
identification case he's really good the
state only did the burden of proof
because it is the burden on the state to
prove their identity and we believe we
have done that but this charge
1.35.10 is really in an identification
case so we didn't propose it well and
135 11
so is that being withdrawn oh no 135 11
we feel has to be charged
so it's really
10 identification reliability that
starts on the bottom of page 10 and goes
to the middle of page 11
that addresses
identification by some person who may
know or not know that person but we do
feel
1.35.11 should be charged
well but if we deal first with 1.35.10
we also had sought to ask that it be
excluded it does not seem appropriate
and i added that in because normally it
comes in and the pattern 135 11 was
asked for without modifications so
why does everything about this trial
seem more professional and sensible than
the written house trial i'm removing the
identification but if we're going to
keep 135 11 it needs to be tailored
because right now
at least what i understand
[Music]
well let's throw this out your honor i
think when we originally began the case
we were
not sure
what the state was going to be
asserting with respect to who had been
on that video the three the four other
nights before
the state did drop back from that even
though you did not give a stipulation
that it's a mod arbory all of it's it's
an it's assumed it's implied it's
assumed and no one disputes that that's
a mod arbory in the house on those other
occasions
that's why i would have wanted to have
an identification charge if there had
been some dispute about it but
our clients are there on the scene
having called 9-1-1
the shots fired
and there the police come and there they
are and they say hey this is what we all
did these are the roles we all took this
isn't it who done it
so for that reason i think
identification just muddies the water
we concur
so are you
instructions being hammered out in
brunswick georgia we'll have more right
after this stay with us
all right so the written house jury is
just moments from entering their 25th
hour of deliberation we have a view
outside the courthouse everything is
still quiet so i'm going to step away
for the time being we are going to keep
the stream going feel free to chat we
will keep banning people participating
in bad faith and then we'll be back with
voicemails and a whole bunch of
different things maybe a verdict today
we are standing by for it
sorry i was muted for a second there
welcome back everybody we are standing
by in the deliberations of the kyle
rittenhouse trial um there is some
potential news about the mistrial and
i'm going to get to that momentarily
appreciate everybody who's been standing
by and watching the stream i do want to
take a look at the latest update in
terms of the counter
um
okay they'll be right i believe they're
into their 26th or 27th hour
of deliberation but here is the big news
that is going on right now
we may be getting to a point where
before the week is out
uh the judge will rule on the on the
multiple mistrial requests
now we don't know that
we don't know that the the there's a
concerning scenario for some
where verdicts come back guilty
and then the judge goes mistrial see
everybody later
um we're gonna wait and see
but here's the latest from newsweek
two mistrial requests are looming over
the kyle rittenhouse homicide trial as
the jury enters its fourth day of
deliberations on friday after sitting
for a total of 23 hours
judge schrader is yet to rule on a
controversial motion with prejudice
filed on tuesday over prosecutorial
overreaching and the withholding of
high-resolution drone footage the
defense initially claimed the
prosecution deliberately sent them lower
quality video evidence but it was later
discovered the video was compressed when
sent over email
if the judge decides to side with the
defense on the mistrial it could append
a possible verdict reached with the jury
by the jury and stop written house from
being retried on the same charges in the
future
um
so
that ruling
sort of in a general sense could come at
any time
um the judge has made himself pretty
scarce today
um but we are we are watching all of it
and there is a slightly bigger crowd
forming the crowd tends to really get
going in the afternoon remember it's
only 11 20 a.m from the standpoint of
central time at the courthouse right now
the pan-african flag has arrived
you can see the the little kyle
rittenhouse effigy
that's the one that says something like
convict killer kyle all with k's so it's
like an allusion to kkk
and uh it's it's not one that i've
endorsed or attacked i'm simply
reporting to you what it is that is
there
um but right now more of a media
presence if anybody knows there's a
there's an individual here holding a
microphone interviewing someone if
that's a feed we could find
i would love to find that feed for us to
examine and review
um i would i mean i think it's something
that
we should look at looking at that very
strongly yeah i would want to take a
look at that
um but i'm not aware
we are also getting close to a very key
moment in the day at this trial
which is
lunchtime let's take a break lunch is
here now i think that our ability to
know
what lunch is today will be limited i
don't imagine that the jury will be
called back into the courtroom simply
for the judge to say it's now time for
lunch or to make any kind of
announcement about what they have but we
have subway tomorrow by the way how are
the calzones the food is here pizza is
here warm food around noon all right how
was the kfc very good enjoy your lunch
right i don't think we're going to get
any of that today
they'll just bring it straight back to
the jury room um and that's sort of
going to be it now i do want to tell you
guys about something that it's it's not
related
but it is one of the funniest things
funniest funniest things
you know how we joke around about
trump's semi-literacy
and well joke we talk about trump's
semi-literacy and this entire thing and
like you know trump's executive orders
are written in crayon
trump is putting out a book
which many former presidents do
it's a picture book
um you really can't write this stuff the
washington examiner
is uh i mean even look at this
the huge book printed in america like
it's an there's there's an element of
this where like the book is physically
big it's a coffee state table style
collection of photographs
that the former president selected
himself for which he wrote captions
oh
trump's book is a picture book i mean
it's like guys you it's it's you can't
write this stuff you can't write this
stuff
um
and look at some of the captions attempt
here's a picture of him with nancy
pelosi and vice president mike pence
attempting to listen to crazy nancy in
the oval office such natural
disagreement
it's a picture book guys it's a picture
book
and he supposedly wrote the captions
they're like tweet style captions
it's it's stunning it's absolutely
stunning and we're gonna be we're gonna
be looking at that in more detail
um
we're going to look at that on monday on
the monday program
okay
i want to say two thank yous to people
who just signed up on my website steven
zollindick
and michael blakeborough
who just signed up at joinpackman.com
numbers 11 and 12 today i very much
appreciate that
um let's see what else we have here
voicemails continue to pour in as we
stand by here for possibly some kind of
uh revelation
oh boy dershowitz is going to be on
court tv that should be interesting
uh court tv doing sort of historical
content at this point in time but we are
standing by um a few
voicemails that have been coming in let
me see if i can get some for you here
hey david this is josh from nebraska
i've been trying to find out if that
second uh guy that brought a gun to the
rittenhouse courthouse
yesterday was
pro written house or not i think he was
pro-written house
but i saw something on twitter saying
that 300 proud boys were coming with
their rifles to kenosha uh to protect
the courthouse have you seen anything
about that
i have not actually seen anything about
that
i have not seen anything about that but
it's definitely something i would
explore
explore
um let's see what else we've got here
there's a lot i mean the voicemails are
just pouring in
hey david this is steven from wisconsin
i was listening to your conversation
with destiny yesterday and i just
i just can't
understand that you're how you have so
much patience with a guy who's so
arrogant and just strawman's you through
the whole thing
i just honestly i just don't take any of
it seriously and
i know there's uh some kind of there
must be some deeper relationship i don't
get i've only heard him on your show but
it's so many things like when you were
trying to explain that there are
elements of entertainment
to your show
and then he just turns around and says
oh well that makes more sense if you
space just entertainment and then you
call him out on that and he just
turns around and says well no that's
exactly what you said yeah and
i'm it's shocking to me that you
just have these long conversations with
him so often because he's just so
disrespectful and arrogant to you but
you just
seem so respectful to him
well you know i i do what i can i do
want to let you guys know that right now
or a little earlier or a little later
today we don't know the exact timing
we
have uh the first female president of
the united states
joe biden is undergoing a routine
colonoscopy
and as a result
because
he is accepting the general deep
sedation or general anesthesia
he has to turn over power to kamala
harris so we have our first female
president
of all time today you might remember
that donald trump
didn't want to turn power over to mike
pence during trump's colonoscopy so he
decided to forego the anesthesia he was
so horrified about the idea of having to
even for an hour to turn power over
to mike pence that trump didn't do that
um so that is uh that that is very very
interesting i want to say thank you to
forrest hughes
who just signed up on my website with
the coupon code uncharged piccolos and
that coupon captioning not available
yes no
let's see what people think
we are getting we're now only a few
hours of deliberation from this going
over the weekend into next week
which would be quite interesting so we
are getting that poll going feel free to
vote in it
um initial reaction from the audience is
53 no 47 yes that's pretty close let's
allow more people to participate just to
get a better
better sense of it
let's listen to a couple of other
voicemails here
hey david uh steph from wisconsin here i
just want to say thank you for
continuing to cover the trial
uh all my friends and family around me
are holding out for a fully
guilty verdict um
but they they don't follow politics as
much as me so they're all relying on me
to keep them updated um and so i i
really appreciate that
and i also want to say um
what was his name sam peter uh it's
[ __ ] when he said excuse me it's uh
bs when he said um
that no one wants to listen to david
pakman in the shower i'm sorry but i've
listened to your bonus show
most of the time i'm listening to it in
the shower before i go to work wow
he's wrong but i think wow
that's a major revelation
that is compelling someone should be
calling in sam cedar about that
what's more likely trump had a
colonoscopy without anesthesia or he got
anesthesia and left us without a
president yeah
oh someone says actually the first woman
acting president was woodrow wilson's
wife while he was ill i didn't know that
so okay let's see about that
woodrow wilson's wife
president
edith bowling galt wilson
let's see
hmm
it's not clear that that was official
though from what i'm reading it's not
clear that that was it seems like we
okay i'm not going to comment on that
because i should i should be
investigating that
i think the jury's logarithms are up in
the air that's what's taking so long how
long before scotus overturns big things
do you think it will activate enough
voters to swing states or elections in
24 no idea that's a really big question
i'm not sure
david i even watch your show in the
shower did you catch jordan b peterson
on rubin report uh that it's cringe
i don't know that i can subject the
audience to that level of cringe let's
see dave rubin jordan peterson
i mean i'm willing to look at a few
seconds of it just to see but i don't i
can't torture my audience with that oh
whoops hold on a second
peterson
rubin oh my god
here it is
let's go to my dock at night up north
has that unearthed anything that maybe
you thought wasn't as intense i think i
think the thing that surprised me the
most probably was
how rapidly we stampeded to imitate a
totalitarian state in the immediate
aftermath of the release of kovit no oh
my god
what does he mean by the release by the
way even that's odd am i missing with
the release of covid a little bit
no one really knew how serious the virus
was going to be and so it was an unknown
threat
and so you can imagine a herd of animals
or a school of fish for for that matter
because this kind of phenomena is
universal throughout the animal kingdom
the cost of over reacting to a threat is
generally minimal compared to under
reacting to a real threat right
overreacting to a hypothetical threat is
cheap compared to under-reacting to an
actual threat because if you under-react
you can die whereas if you over-react
you generally just get tired for a
minute so a hurdle stampede because the
most neurotic member of the herd jumps
first and then they'll instantly follow
them and that's kind of what we did in
the early stages of the pandemic the
chinese acted first now unfortunately
they are a totalitarian state and we all
followed and that's excusable in some
sense because we didn't know what sort
of threat we were facing
but then the
the breakdown it's really appalling in
canada the breakdown of our our rights
let's say for a moment my god
it's so boring like who even cares what
he says at this point i i find it all so
boring
ruben interviewing jordan peterson it's
like we're are we back to that routine
uh where it's just oh my god
i want i'm more you know who's more
interesting to me than jordan peterson
uh paula questa and christian rady who
just signed up on my website i'd rather
talk to you guys over jbp or pbj or
whatever
any time of day
kevin says supporting the stream during
your time out after this complete
insanity wraps up you should see if pas
le vanciana will come on huge music
counter culture argentine cultural
appeal crossover appeal i don't know
what that is
uh
it's not returning a single
result
in google that's weird
so i don't know what that is
strange
don't read too much into it the release
is an accurate depiction of a virus
escaping a captive population into a
wider population an outbreak all right
pacman is a dangerous ideologue
disguised in the cloak of reasonableness
whoa
that's pretty serious
edith wilson assumed control as
president while her husband was
incapacitated technically it was a coup
she signed executive orders for more
than a year wow that is presidential
history that that was not on my radar
i will uh i need to read more about that
for sure
um let's see
what's happening over on court tv if
members of the public say oh my god john
smith's on that jury don't they know
that he oh my god dershowitz this is
that
um so there is some sacrifice that's
being made but i think anonymous juries
are essential in certain cases but when
you
limit them to certain cases it sends a
dangerous message it started with mafia
juries
um and when a juror in new york
discovered that they were uh anonymous
they said to themselves oh my god is
gotti gonna come and get me is is this
mafia guy gonna come and get me and they
were scared so we have to be sensitive
to all the issues growing out of
anonymous juries but i think juries
should generally be kept anonymous
until at least some time after the trial
is over
professor alan dershowitz uh this is all
really really helpful insight you're
sharing with us
would you kindly stay uh to do a little
more in this segment because we'd love
to ask you about whether you think the
charging in some of these big
high-profile cases has potentially been
influenced by the mob on the outside i
can i can say a few more minutes yes
very good uh professor thank you so much
we're going to squeeze in a break we'll
be right back with arguably the nation's
leading expert
they're squeezing in a break there very
powerfully
at an exactly perfect time as we
continue to stand by here to see what on
earth is going on with jury
deliberations quite extraordinary what
is taking place here
um
crazy work schedule caused me to miss
some live streams did the community let
the mustache die
um on wednesday
wait on wednesday yeah wednesday we
failed to get the requisite 50 new
members and the mustache was removed
david love the show do you think kyle
will be charged with reckless
endangerment we know the charges already
there's a list of five charges so i'm
not
i don't know what you mean about i mean
there's already charges
maybe i'm misunderstanding the question
did you transfer power when you shave
the mustache yeah when i was in
shaving my mustache
i did briefly transfer power
um to sam cedar
just in case and then i resumed it very
quickly david how does someone leave you
a voicemail you call two one nine two
david p two one nine two david p
let's listen to another voicemail or two
that continue to come in
hey david sarah from mass you were just
on the alex jones show
it's awesome um he did a montage of all
the athletes dying
in the country from the uh vaccine
and uh you had a voiceover in it he
clowned your ass dude
if alex jones really just talked about
me i would love uh
i i would love to
get clips of that there are so many
people getting banned it's it's actually
starting to get
really sad
and honestly if you don't like my show
just
go watch something else nobody's forcing
you to be here we're just going to keep
banning people
um i am seeing people saying that the
verdict is
in is that true
where are people seeing that
uh let's see
verdict i don't know if people are
trolling me but
it's just trolling i mean nobody's
saying it's in now they're saying it'll
be read in an hour but let's see
i'm not seeing anything right now
yeah not not seeing anything right now
okay
so
we'll stand by
uh
fox news is reporting it i i just don't
think so
yeah fox news doesn't seem to be
reporting anything of the sort
okay very good well wow you tricked me
guys you tricked me
hey david
i just want to let you know
uh bryce is from nebraska and not only
do people watch and listen to the shower
but they also do it while dropping
pickles in the toilet
uh keep doing what you're doing and i
love your show
okay
hi david um it's whitney um
i would just uh emailed you um just some
details about my court
um case today i was wondering if maybe
you could look into it if i don't call
you okay i don't know i don't know
anything about that i don't know
anything about that i want to be really
careful about that
um
dear god
do you prefer uncharged pickle and
butter pickles or uncharged dill uh
probably just half sours i doubt a
verdict today maybe more debate about a
mistrial or an actual mistrial
david goodread for you on the wilson
presidency edith and woodrow the wilson
white house lisa drew books all right
very good
very very powerful stuff
we are monitoring all of it we are
monitoring all of it
and let's see now if we go back to court
tv
if they have anything on this
by the threat of mob violence in the
charging and in the quick charging of
these cases
i have no doubt about that not only by
the threat of violence but by the threat
of not being
reelected
they are following them up you know you
have to remember this is something that
most americans don't appreciate
we are the only country in the history
of the western world categorical the
only country ever to elect prosecutors
it's a disaster that we have elected
prosecutors no other country in the
world has it our prosecutors run not
only for re-election but virtually every
member of the house and the senate who
are lawyers have been prosecutors so
being a prosecutor is a
stepping stone toward higher elective
office and so prosecutors are far far
too influenced by not only the mob
but also by by voters and they shouldn't
be
in every other country in the world
being a prosecutor is a civil service
job and
decisions are made based on the law not
on popular appeal so we have a real
problem in this country and it's become
exacerbated but merely exacerbated it
was always a problem but it's become
exacerbated by the okay folks we do have
the first twitter blue check mark
element that i'm aware of
that the verdict is in
carol markowitz carol markowitz
columnist at the new york post and fox
news
does have a tweet
got a reliable tip
that the written house verdict is in
and will be announced in the next hour
this is the first what i would i mean
listen this is not a guarantee of
anything but this is a serious reporter
um
this is now
a signal
that the verdict may indeed be in
okay so we're going to keep an eye out
the verdict may be in
the verdict may be in we don't know we
are watching and we are standing by cnn
is not yet reporting anything etc etc
okay this is just one reporter telling
us what is going on if this is true
it is imminently urgent that if you are
planning on using the coupon code
uncharged pickles that you do it now at
the time that the verdict is in that
code is going to go away uncharged
piccolos so please if you've been
enjoying the streams and everything and
you want us to keep going and going into
the the arbory trial and everything
would love your support join pakman.com
is the place to do it
for now it's a schrodinger's cat
uh
yeah
not exactly sure what people are talking
about there
uh we're continuing to watch here
if you're just joining us
fox news
uh
we'll see columnist at the new york post
and fox news contributing editor to the
spectator contributing writer to the dc
examiner carol markowitz says that she
has received a reliable tip
this was from 15 minutes ago that the
verdict is in and will be announced in
the next hour okay oh by the way can i
just this is this is not a joke
okay i'm not joking when i say this not
a joke yeah
last night i had a calzone for dinner
because of the because of this trial
all of the all of the calzone stuff by
the way how are the calzones i
legitimately got done with the stream
last night
and i was like i want to get a calzone
and i got a veggie calzone
beautiful marinara
and it was really great
it was really great um all right let's
quote retweet
anybody have more info corroboration
so i did get a yeah it was a fantastic i
have to tell you it was a great calzone
it was a really really good calzone
uh okay if we start seeing more people
gather here
i believe that this would also be a sign
that the verdict may be coming soon
um let's close out things that we don't
need and oh hold on a second let's see
what's going on back um to to haunt the
judge with a decision like that or would
the error
just be so harmless that hey look if
anything this person's just getting a
more uh clear picture of what the
instructions contain
well it could help on an argument that
the instructions themselves were wrong
the instructions were wrong
they were not good instructions you know
there were two trials in written house
completely different trials the
prosecutor put written house on trial
for being there to having a gun
for
uh being part of the demonstration you
should have stayed home okay very good
all right here's what we're gonna do i'm
gonna try i'm gonna step away just for a
second
oh i did just plant fall garlic i just
planted it very good question j.e i
planted my fall garlic today that's why
i'm wearing my my hoodie i'm gonna step
away and try to get a determination as
to whether the uh oh hold on a second
we gotta ban a couple more people i'm
gonna try to find out whether the
verdict is in it very well may be i'm
going to be right back if the verdict is
in we're going to be here straight
through we're going to be doing
uncharged pickles we're going to be
doing dills half sours uh pastrami on
corned beef pastrami and corn beef on
rye we're going to be doing all of it
okay stand by
all right everybody i'm back i i've been
doing a little bit of research um i have
i am finding nothing other than this one
reporter carol markowitz saying that the
verdict is coming
she has sent a follow-up tweet
saying
[Music]
uh wait hold on or is it
i was going back and forth if i should
post it because it's so not my lane i
followed the trial but not like many of
you
but information wants to be free
and again this person is reliable and
has given me correct tips before
um
that is interesting that is very very
interesting let's see if anyone
is quote tweeting with any additional
information
um
other than me
let's see
not really
this is really all we have right now
julie bosman twitter julie bosman
twitter
let's see what julie bosman has to say
chicago bureau chief
the idea is the jury will want to wrap
things up in time to enjoy the
quintessential wisconsin friday night
meal yeah i mentioned the weekend thing
earlier i don't see
let's see another tea leaf jurors have
just been put in an order for lunch
that is a sign that we are not about to
get a verdict if they've just ordered
lunch
i don't think we're about to get a
verdict
wow
interesting
okay so here's someone else
guys i mean if they're if they're if
they're just ordering lunch right now
it's hard to imagine that they were
about to get a verdict
but uh we're going to keep watching it
we're going to keep watching it let's
see if anything else is happening here
alan dershowitz still speaking
there is more of a crowd starting to
gather outside the courthouse but that
tends to be happening
uh every day at this time so i don't
know that that really tells us anything
um and it is getting we are nine minutes
from noon in kenosha and you know what
that could mean warm food around noon
yeah
and that probably signals no uh no no
verdict so we don't know
let me say thank you to people signing
up on my website look at these great
people katie finnegan and emily mckenna
have just signed up thanks to the two of
you
i really appreciate that new members 16
and 17.
welcome to candice guerrero and roman
grigorev
also leonelle campos and corey cheshire
cheshire
that's four
puts us at 21. and how could i forget
sonia otis
and nicholas stark oh hey nicholas great
to see you as well
that puts us at 23
and lastly shortcakes shortcakes is a
new member at joinpakman.com number 24.
the crowd is starting to gather and
there are more and more people showing
up is it possible they know something
there
that we don't yet know
it's certainly possible
certainly possible
um
oh hold on i gotta ban a couple more
people
yep a few more bands
all right
let's continue to monitor whether carol
markowitz has posted anything else
nothing yet let's see about julie bosman
nothing newer than an hour
let's do a general twitter search
written house
verdict and look at latest
okay
i'm excited
media sources are stating announcement
of the written house verdict is imminent
who is that
breaking jury reaches verdict
possible written house verdict
written house verdict reached
kenosha police sent out an email in
about 45 minutes uh oh
oh boy police are getting ready
verdict coming rumblings of a verdict
written house verdict announced in the
next hour oh boy
it may be happening
wow so we are now starting to see
many many messages
uh
written house verdict jury has reached a
verdict per oan well okay
take that for word it's worth written
house verdict expected i'm gonna wait if
someone can give me something reliable
i will change the title here
chant check your email let's see
whitten house okay yeah right but that's
what we looked at
um let's just see we will change the
title of the stream and we will go into
verdict mode if indeed appropriate but
not prematurely
we may have a verdict we're we're
we're trying to figure it out everybody
relax
everybody just relax like eventually we
will have a verdict and i'm going to let
you guys know
let's see here
any kind of
contempt of court charge
with this court in kenosha county
probably not only because it didn't go
as far as it could have um all we know
is that this person mr morrison blew
through a red light got a ticket for it
he was released it doesn't seem he
gained any information from it and
there's been so many problems
surrounding this case i doubt they would
want another one so no i don't think
they would pursue a contempt of court
sure and there's no evidence just to be
very clear no evidence that he
photographed anything and it was
expressed that his intent was not to
make contact with any all right we're
continuing to listen and to stand by
more and more people are posting about
the verdict
let's see what else we've got
nothing new from carol markowitz
nothing new from julie bosman yet
and then over just a straight written
house verdict search
new york times has it
let's see
per new york times
arbory
not seeing it
do you mean the new york times website
it's happening guys
jury written house jury said to reach a
decision two people familiar say the
jury has reached a decision
the new york times has it the new york
times has it the jury has reached a
decision all right let's change
our
um
title here
live
breaking urgent kyle rittenhouse
verdict
reached announcement
imminent
all right
here we go guys the verdict has been
reached as of four minutes ago the new
york times
reporting that deliberations are now
over deliberations are over in the
written house trial according to two
people familiar with proceedings the
12-person jury in the homicide trial of
kyle rittenhouse has reached a decision
the jury heard closing arguments and
instructions monday started at 9 15
central tuesday continued deliberating
through the week has not been
sequestered
um
eight minutes ago relatives of the
people whom written house killed have
entered the courtroom for the first time
in several days
there is every indication this is going
on although we had this
ah
even the the request for lunch may have
been an accused request
an alleged request for lunch but the
jury didn't actually ask for it they
were going by when the jury is typically
typically typically requesting lunch
um
[Music]
wow
wow
warm food around noon
yeah so uh there is a much larger crowd
starting to gather there is every
indication every indication that a
verdict has been reached here and that
it will be read imminently
i am shocked and appalled
that i was able to get a calzone last
night just before the end of the trial
uh but i was i want to say thank you to
people dumping in memberships fully
charged pickle coming in very strongly
just got a new membership sherry
nymphius and amanda adams just signed up
on my website joinpakman.com which puts
us at 27. the crowd is gathering let's
see if there's audio
you're stealing that right now
they're doing the white they're going to
figure out their white balance which we
will allow them to do
a much larger crowd starting to gather
at the kenosha courthouse
it is unclear if the jurors have had
lunch but there are now multiple reports
that a verdict has been reached and
could be read
within the hour we're going to end the
poll because the poll is about whether a
verdict will be reached today
um and people said yes okay by a very
very small margin
um written house guilty of wanting warm
food at noon let's calm down eat some
fruit or something msnbc announced the
victims families have been called to the
courthouse
um
yes a lot a lot a lot of stuff
coming in via super chat i appreciate
everybody giving me information if
you're just joining us we believe a
verdict has been reached we believe a
verdict has been reached we are covering
the new york times update on this
um
written house jury said to reach a
decision two people familiar with the
proceedings say the jury has reached the
decision after deliberating three and a
half days
who shot three okay etcetera so that's
what's going on
uh let's get a new poll going because
this may be happening well now it's
getting crazy all right now it's getting
crazy let's do a new poll
what will the written house verdict be
guilty on all counts
guilty on some counts
uh
i think it's no longer a hung jury
because i think they've got a verdict so
let's see guilty on all counts as
written
no can't do that guilty on all accounts
guilty on some counts
guilty of some i don't even know how to
do i'll we'll forget about lesser
charges not guilty on all counts
we're just gonna go with it that way
yeah verdict means no hung jury
very good
whether you think lesser charges or not
it's just a question about whether there
will be any guilty verdicts uh we are
now in a countdown to the reading live
of the kyle rittenhouse verdict the jury
has reportedly reached a verdict the
families of victims
have been called to the courthouse for
the first time
in days
and
we may be seeing
that verdict potentially within the hour
potentially within the hour four days of
deliberation
can the judge still declare a mistrial
yes
yes
uh moderators please be on alert i'm
expecting that we are going to get
absolutely flooded by some of the most
horrible people on the internet
and
we are going to be
everybody knows what the plan is we know
who to ban
and that is going to be looked at very
very strongly
court tv not reporting anything yet but
as you can see the camera here seems to
be preparing for a verdict to be read
things are starting to get set up here
we have audio outside the courthouse
if you're just joining us the verdict
has been reached per the new york times
per msnbc and others and others
if necessary we will switch to members
only chat it was a four millibate
video
exactly
something is going on yes the verdict
the verdict appears to have been reached
oh they are in the courtroom folks this
may be it they may just be going right
to the verdict right now
wow folks it may be happening
oh and the cough is getting even worse
all right the uh
we're back and the appearances before
with the jury upstairs
and they have notified us that they have
just reached a verdict verdict reached
anything before
we call the jury down they're doing
they're just doing it guys
wow folks
memberships are jump dumping in scott
stanton todd hemsel is a new member sean
klinger has signed up corey flintoff
diane foskey and paula morgan
that's six new members in like 20
seconds
wow what a day what a day
the verdict has been reached the verdict
has been reached
court tv is not even covering it
what on earth is going on we have a
verdict
you can vote in the chat a plural a
majority says guilty on some counts
send us a super chat tell us
what you believe the verdict will be
wow
wow
this is gonna be it for uncharged
pickles uncharged piccolos coupon code
right above me
when we have a verdict it will go away
it has been great being with everybody
throughout this trial we are going to
continue coverage even after the verdict
because we want to see
what if anything is going to be taking
place outside in
kenosha we have a crowd starting to
gather more and more on the steps of the
courthouse which we will be monitoring
very closely
court tv seems to be realizing that
there is indeed a verdict coming
and uh it could be anything it could be
anything the courthou courthouse busier
than we've seen it
this all came together
very quickly
and of course
what if the judge declares a mistrial
what if the judge declares a mistrial
we still don't have an answer to that
i want to say thanks to carlos paino
who just signed up on my website carlos
thank you it's been great having you
here throughout our coverage of the
trial i think we're more than
maybe a few minutes
a hundred hours in
let's refresh over here and see if we
prefer the court tv feed
maybe we will
actually this feed is quite delayed so
maybe we'll stick with this one the
judge smirking about the entire thing
maybe realizing it's the last few
minutes he will get to be on tv every
day
everybody looking very very nervous
and this sometimes you get a full hour
but uh
we just learned about this about 10-15
minutes ago and they are already
bringing the jury in
i want to say thanks to casey gilson who
just signed up on my website thanks
casey very much appreciate it
also thanks to john perrutz and james
moore
um it's it's
it's been amazing uh people support
during this trial and we will likely go
uh monday into the
other trial
if any of the other judges are welcome
that's the only exception um
by the way
um a couple of three different ways to
communicate um
what you think will happen we have a
poll going on youtube that you can vote
in 71 of you believe they will there
will be at least one guilty verdict you
can participate in the regular chat on
youtube
you can also send a super chat
this is a critical moment this is the
end
seven percent of you believe it will be
guilty on all counts
22 percent of you believe it will be not
guilty on all counts
and 71 of you believe there will be some
guilty verdicts
some guilty verdicts
i want to say thanks to shannon greene
for signing up at
joinpakman.com thank you shannon
also kevin campbell just signed up using
the coupon code uncharged pickles
uncharged piccolos that's number 39.
the uh it may be a few minutes
before the jury makes it up
we have been advised of that
the judge uh having some kind of a cough
drop of sorts unclear if there are
menthol elements in it i want to say
thanks to mr yee for making a patreon
pledge those count double today they
count as two
daniel parks also signing up at
joinpakman.com using that very same
coupon code uncharged piccolos and his
new member number 42 today
this seemingly will be the conclusion of
our coverage of the kyle rittenhouse
trial although the judge could still
declare a mistrial without prejudice
with prejudice we may have a whole new
trial we really don't know the judge has
not yet ruled on the two different
mistrial requests
hannah lake is a new member thanks
hannah appreciate you signing up at
joinpackman.com number 43 today uh for
those of you
in the audience portion
um
no it doesn't need to be
um
there can't be any reaction at all no
matter how strongly you may feel
and it's understood that many people do
have strong feelings
but we can't permit and permit any kind
of a
reaction to the verdict and as you can
see there's quite a bit of law
enforcement here and
you will be whisked out of here if there
is any so just be aware
the jury is coming in folks we will be
looking at this count by count i have my
legal pad here
one two three four five counts
we are moments from the verdict
the entire case leading to this
okay
thanks to lynn payton for signing up on
my website thank you lynn i really
appreciate your support
now there's a phone ringing
hello would you go down please yes thank
you all right jury will be coming in
augustine popa
just signed up on my website
number 45 today i very much appreciate
that
the outpouring of support particularly
in the context of us being banished from
tvitch for 30 days
is very heartwarming
five counts
and there will be five verdicts five
counts five verdicts
thanks to christine gilchrist and andrew
billings for signing up on my website
also matt mulholland and susan ozelin
that puts us at 49 today
you guys are the best i really
appreciate the the the audiences that
have been here we estimate around 1.5
million different stream starts took
place during coverage of the trial
oh sorry
thanks to espress for the hundred dollar
super chat says thanks for providing
coverage and thanks to everyone for
pickle jokes
sorry sorry i didn't realize it wasn't
full screen
we could be under five minutes from the
verdict thanks to patty gifford and dana
wingate for signing up on my website
numbers 50 and 51.
the website is uh under
serious load right now
all right members of the jury have you
uh elected a far person
would you uh here it is five charges
guys give your journal please 54. 54.
and uh has the jury reached a verdict as
to each account of the information yes
we have your honor one verdict and one
verdict only yes would you hand all the
paperwork to the bailiff please this is
the one that you didn't know
yeah everything yeah thanks
wow
so the judge first has to look at
everything and we'll make sure
everything's in order and in good
standing yeah see that too
thank you
thanks to lance mcgee for signing up on
my website appreciate that lance also
dylan bush is a new member at this
critical moment an outpouring of support
for independent media
i will read everybody's names after
as the judge reviews the verdicts
and then they will be read
and then we will see what happens
outside the courthouse as you can see a
much larger crowd outside the courthouse
at this time
[Applause]
if people wanna
face the jury and hearken to its
verdicts oh boy here we go
joseph
defendant
rosenbaum
h rick house not guilty not guilty as to
the second count of the information
richard mcinnis we the jury by the
defendant kyle h ridden house not guilty
not guilty as to the third count of the
information unknown mail we the jury
find the defendant kyle h written house
not guilty not guilty as to the fourth
count of the information anthony huber
we the jury find the defendant kyle h
rittenhouse not guilty
as to the fifth count of the information
gage rose croix we the jury find the
defendant kyle edward kyle h house not
guilty
not guilty on all charges the jury are
these your unanimous verdicts
is there anyone who does not agree with
the verdicts as read
would you wish the jury pulled
okay
uh okay folks your job is done and uh
we
started just about three weeks ago
and i uh i told you it could last
two weeks and two days this is two weeks
this is three weeks
uh you were a wonderful jury to work
with you were punctual you were
attentive
and
the forgotten six over here who had a
very
difficult job of
keeping from discussing the case during
the time that they were sequestered as
well
all of you you just i couldn't have
asked for a better jury to work with
and uh it has truly been my pleasure
uh
you i think without commenting on your
verdict the verdicts themselves
just in terms of your um
the attentiveness and the cooperation
that you gave to us
uh this
justifies the confidence
that the founders of our country placed
in you
so um
i dismiss you at this time you're never
under any obligation to discuss any
aspect of this case with anyone
you're welcome to do so as little or as
much as you want
the media have requested a number of
media sources have requested the ability
to
talk to you and
they have been
allowed to present
presentations to you that you'll get in
writing and it's entirely up to you
whether you want content contact them
they are not to contact you
um
if anyone does contact you and just
you tell them you're not interested in
discussing it if that's the case
and if anyone persists in doing so
report that to us and it will be
addressed i assure you
at the beginning of the trial uh there
was some concern
about uh information and uh
and your safety
and i assure you that we will take every
measure to ensure that that is
your concerns are addressed and
respected
um and um
i'm going to talk to you for just a
minute not about anything to do with the
case but just about that sole issue and
um
um
you as i say you're welcome to discuss
the case as little or as much as you
want
and
any questions anybody
thank you so much
and
you're um you're after four years you're
eligible for service again
it would be my pleasure to work with you
thank you
so notice rittenhouse being let out
immediately presumably there was a plan
that they need to get him out there i i
think that there are security concerns
about rittenhouse they seem to usher him
out very quickly there
and we are monitoring what is going on
outside the courthouse
if people have feeds from in kenosha
that we should switch to when this is
done please let me know so that we can
get to those and see what is going to
transpire or hopefully not outside the
courthouse
and quite a crowd now starting to gather
mr richards
any word from the state
the jury has
our community in this trial and has
spoken
all right the notion of the defendant is
granted um
charges against the defendant on all
counts are dismissed with prejudice
and he is released from the obligation
of his bond anything else no here we are
thank you good day
and that is it ladies and gentlemen
and
a serious presence developing outside
the courthouse clearly as you may have
seen they ushered out the former
defendant kyle rittenhouse
presumably some concerns about his
safety
and now we are going to see
what is the reaction from the community
um i don't know
who may be streaming
outside the courthouse
we do have this one shot which we are
going to be looking at but if folks have
others that may be there
i certainly am interested in seeing what
is going on
uh i believe let's see
okay we have one feed here from right
outside the courthouse
and we have a second feed
okay very good
ladies and gentlemen the verdict has
been reached it is not guilty on all
counts not guilty on all counts for kyle
rittenhouse
youtube i'm trying to get one other feed
here for us
okay yeah news to share isn't live so i
don't know
why someone directed me to that but they
are not live
uh
it's not clear to me
whether these folks know the verdict yet
i just don't know
but we are monitoring
so many super chats coming in so many
people wanting to weigh in
i do want to say thank you to people who
have been signing up
uh john malone
elber gallarga
chris yanez has signed up i appreciate
that
denise bertolozzi
jonas witzel
james edgar
vicki de paolo has signed up
so we're monitoring right outside the
courthouse here
the question of course is what happens
now
in kenosha
let's see here
see what transpires over the next few
hours but
as we've reported and you what we all
watch live kyle rittenhouse a free man
he will presumably uh be walked
um
same way he comes in every day
entrance he's not gonna
and we've got some disruption there as
you can see with the signal with ted
rollins outside of the courthouse we'll
do our best to rectify that in the
meantime i have judge ashley wilcott
with me in the studio here at core tv
headquarters judge your reaction to the
verdict please holy smokes i didn't mean
to interrupt you julie i know we've all
been on pins and needles now on day four
of this and holy smokes because of this
i think that this defense really did do
a good job of saying nope it is
self-defense in this jury it boiled down
to is it self-defense or not wow what a
what a day an incredible incredible
result here
as things are starting to
legal
happen
people like the mccluskies from saint
louis
who practice the same
practice the same behavior by pulling
their weapons for no reason on peaceful
protesters this
is disturbing at best and it is
unacceptable at the highest level
[Music]
i'm not so surprised because in this
city my nephew was shot seven times in
the back and no level no charges were
ever leveled you have to understand from
day one the judge had his hand on the
scale he didn't allow pictures he didn't
allow videotapes and he didn't allow
he was doing everything he could to
allow this young man to lead his
coursework
lines over the eyes of the jurors
so as you can hear significant honking
taking place in the background and now
it's a question as to what happens next
[Music]
the ideal thing would be that this crowd
disperses and that it does not escalate
i think the longer people stay and the
more honking there is the higher the
propensity becomes for things to get out
of
and everything control involved in this
case that did not ringtones blood from
trump the judge said he doesn't like
raptures he calls him right
[Music]
things fortunately remaining pretty calm
for the time being and we're going to
watch it significant police presence has
been deployed
kenosha up here
need
to
for me to show up
okay if that's what it takes what are
their motives
another thing another thing if somebody
told them not to show up who's
controlling them nobody throw me to show
up or not to show up
[Music]
all right so uh tension's uh sort of uh
rising there
but uh so far
nothing um
[Music]
nothing particularly violent which is
good um i want to say thanks to julie
phillips for the patreon pledge those
count double and put us at 61. also big
thank you to julie phillips for the
website membership which is an
additional one puts puts us at 62.
um
there is now movement to get around to
the side and we will see if we actually
see the defend ant exit
[Music]
seems like we're getting around to the
side of the courthouse presumably where
kyle rittenhouse will be leaving
i don't know if he goes directly to fox
news for an interview or if he stops at
home for food first
they may have realized he already left
actually
[Music]
a lot happening here as you can see
does he get to intern for matt gates now
yeah i think so i think so actually matt
gates expressed significant interest in
that
i'm getting emails from people in the
last couple minutes saying they just
heard that a verdict has been reached
and hopefully i will cover it the
verdict was read 10 minutes ago it is
not guilty on all counts not guilty on
all counts for kyle rittenhouse
the jury has spoken
um
look at this guy
saying self-defense and shaking and
walking into someone
[Music]
so a lot of character is certainly
participating here
a number of different people
if you're just joining us kyle
rittenhouse not guilty on all counts was
rushed out very very quickly after the
verdict
[Music]
i will uh yeah
do i see good question do i ever see
myself going to kenosha no
i i listen
i've said before i try to stay away from
these parts of the country where there
are lots of guns and militia culture and
that type of thing i don't um
i try to stay away from those parts of
the country it's just not for me
so no certainly no plans to go to
kenosha
uh by the way we will continue banning
people
that's not going to stop
it's not
apparent that the crowd is building and
this is good in terms of their not being
violence in fact it's starting to sort
of seem like people are wandering away
which is kind of what you want to see
lest this become another situation
another situation like the one that led
to this trial in the first place but
it's sort of seeming like people are
generally walking away rather than
towards the courthouse
uh is the impression that i'm getting
will they prosecute kyle for perjury
seems unlikely to me seems unlikely to
me
let's see what is happening on court
tv's coverage at this time the the audio
in the video kind of dropped out you
were making some points about what you
were seeing outside of the courthouse
you told us that some folks supporting
kyle rittenhouse were cheering and then
ran
ran to get out of there but so far you
said it had been peaceful i want you to
pick back up where we left off please
yeah
and still and still is in fact they seem
to be more prayerful than um
chanting now it's um a quiet scene
outside the courthouse for those on the
courthouse steps that have been here
from the beginning and and you're right
as soon as the verdict was read the pro
kyle folks several of them
literally sprinted away
because of obvious potential concerns
right and i'm being told shanley you
were in there in the courtroom when the
verdict was read what can you share with
us please
yeah julie i was in the courtroom before
the jury entered as security filed in
flanking all sides of the gallery inside
the courtroom a full house standing room
only and the family of kyle rittenhouse
entered emotionally his mother wendy
already crying before she even sat down
to wait for the jury to enter and also
on the side the other side we had the
carrion swarth the fiancee of joseph
rosenbaum hannah giddings susan hughes
they were softly crying even before the
jury entered now as we waited we had to
wait a while for the jury dinner the
alternates entered first and
you know they didn't know what was going
to happen but then the jury filed in and
i i noticed immediately that they didn't
seem weary they didn't seem tense they
even smiled at each other as they sat
down and they were like sitting up in
their seats you know leaning forward
looking at kyle looking at the defense
table and the four person juror number
54 she's a white woman probably in her
50s she's one of those jurors who wore a
mask the entire trial and she handed
over the verdict forms and as they were
read all eyes were on kyle renthouse the
jury all of them looking over towards
him studying his reaction and as not
guilty was read not guilty was read you
could hear the sobs coming from the
gallery and then coming from kyle ridden
house he almost collapsed and was
hugging his attorneys and one time after
count five was right he did collapse
into the desk and it was just a very
emotional
tense inside this courtroom and the jury
even after before actually they were
dismissed still nodding smiling at the
judge filed out of there but the first
one out of the courtroom which i thought
was interesting julie kyle rittenhouse
he almost sprinted out of that courtroom
i've never seen that from a defendant
and it was like he was waiting he wanted
to go see his family he wanted to go
celebrate this victory for him oh wow
chandlee you know i'm sure there are
probably plenty of security protocols
that have been put in place for this
moment that we've all been waiting for
and the exiting of kyle rittenhouse out
of that courtroom and then of course the
members of the jury who we found out
yesterday through what the judge put on
the record with the incident with the
bus
in the way that they're being protected
here on after
ted you've been telling us this week as
you've been outside of the court right
so that is what is happening folks that
is what is happening
um it appears as though things are
remaining
uh
essentially calm at the courthouse
which is what we want no indication that
things are
turning violent at this time
and that's a very very good thing
i really appreciate everybody who has
joined me throughout coverage of the
trial our coverage of the trial is going
to end here and now
but i will be monitoring the situation
in kenosha if things do escalate i will
be back and please do email me if that's
the case but we are going to hope that
things remain calm here
thank you for joining me we will be back
monday with the trial over the killing
of ahmad arbury and then we are going to
be going from there thank you very much
everybody